[Música]
whaaaaat
agora
[Música]
ó
um pequeno estado
nada
ah
até mais real minas gerais
isso é assentar di'anno senhoras e
senhores a gente busca a bater palmas
fica à vontade e energia isso a gente
busca a conexão através da música de
diferentes frequências em torno de um
mesmo propósito música música tem esse
potencial agente isso agora certo
cada um chegou aqui uma frequência cada
um chegou aqui com um propósito
diferente sabendo que o mote desse
evento era esse propósito catártico isso
aqui a gente aprendeu o dia inteiro em
mergulhar o dia inteiro mas para cada
situação existe um propósito diferente
para cada momento da nossa vida existe
um propósito diferente e música tem esse
poder
e essa nossa linguagem com essa
linguagem ficar tranqüilo se comunicar
com vocês
muitas vezes esse propósito e vai girar
em torno de recebimento de uma pessoa da
despedida de uma pessoa de uma pessoa
eventualmente partindo do mundo
eventualmente de um grande abraço de um
momento que a gente quer usar a música
para explicitar tudo aquilo que a gente
está sentindo e é isso que faz a gente
fazer o que a gente faz a gente vai
fazer esse tema que a gente fez agora no
comecinho aqui pra vocês foi um mantra
composto especialmente por ted é uma
honra fazer isso pra vocês e fazer
música exige responsabilidade e pra ter
essa responsabilidade a gente vai
estruturar a música agora da forma mais
óbvia que ela deve ser feita em cima de
três grandes pilares primeiro deles a
rítmica
é o chão rítmica o chão da música por
onde a gente vai caminhar
a onda primeiro contato que teve com
música na sua vida na barriga da sua mãe
o coração batendo sakhan a dar ritmo a
gente vai para o segundo grande ponto da
música urbana de pilar a harmonia é o
caldo
[Música]
aquele troço que ninguém sabe explicar
nem músicos a harmonia isso é aquilo
jogar a todo mundo sabe entender é o
norte é por aqui que a gente vai
a harmonia é ali é pra lá que a gente
vai arrumar o carro vai engrossar agora
para salvar o terceiro grande pilar tão
importante quanto os outros dois
a melodia é o elo entre passado presente
e futuro
aquele troço que seja alguém da família
não admite nó computador
[Música]
quase
vai ser um josé finkel
já responda por favor juazeiro
bom dia
ae
ela nunca mais faltou fazer um bom dia
o amor
é isso o tom baixo
[Música]
ansa
tcheco
ao a campeã
dançar forró
uai
ah
[Música]
salvador
ei
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ae
[Música]
[Aplausos]
isso aqui no finalzinho foi só um
tiquinho da melodia né acho que a gente
fez agora misturou duas diferentes
harmoniza os diferentes melodias para
executar um tema que é uma
reinterpretação joazeiro era um baião ou
indecente um tema clássico do jazz à
santa já faz isso a gente estuda música
tradicional e vai buscar em diferentes
culturas elementos que possam somar
musicalmente pra gente eventualmente se
conectar com você que conhece melhor do
jazz com você que pira em baião com você
que chora horrores quando ouve música
cigana forte né pra mim música cigana
hoje aqui ainda mais perdendo e não vai
ser nossa senhora a no fim das contas
isso aqui vai engrossando todos os
nossos casos é aí que a gente vai
mergulhando e é na rua que a gente gosta
de fazer bagunça
numa situação como essa aqui onde a
gente tá tocando no meio da rua parado
em cima da picape e pula essa criança
fofa em cima junto com a gente ela pega
um triângulo eu nunca tinha visto essa
menina na minha vida alguém tinha visto
essa menina na vida ninguém se tinham
visto a menina na vida é ótimo ela subiu
coluna picape pegou o triângulo começou
a fazer som com a gente
a habilidade dela de fazer som beirava
assim era potente ótico e aquilo ali
orgânicos ea gente fazer um piu ela só
música ali
esse é o caldo é o potencial é desse
propósito que a gente não vai abrir mão
e é pra lá que a gente vai arrumar lá
para gonçalves sul de minas gerais
quando a gente tem um projeto de música
ltda gonçalves aí sim dá um grito
tudo bem gonçalves que a gente tem um
projeto de musicalização com a criançada
lá onde a gente ensina e aprende a gente
fica nublado de música harmonia melodia
ver a criançada outro dia ensinou pra
gente que a tal da marcha guarânia né
a batida rancheira lá a gente achando
que sabia tocar música caipira criançada
assentou a gente falou não não guarani
isso aqui envolve começou
isso é o nosso a nossa busca incessante
por alimentar o nosso propósito
quer fazer a música lavar a nossa alma
senhoras e senhores e agora eu gostaria
de saber nós já estamos na mesma
freqüência
[Música]
ae
não pára
[Música]